we have new information this morning
from a criminal investigation of
disgraced Hollywood producer Harvey
Weinstein tarika Nutkin has been
following this story since it broke in'
joins us now with the latest Rico good
morning good morning Gail CBS News has
learned the Manhattan district
attorney's office informed people
involved in the case they are not
looking to move forward in the
investigation centered around rape
allegations against Harvey Weinstein
those allegations were brought forward
by actress paz de la Huerta who says
Weinstein raped her twice in 2010 while
inside her New York City apartment the
new revelation would be a stark change
from just last month when the New York
Police Department announced the
allegations were credible as they
gathered evidence for a possible arrest
warrant the DA also recently appointed a
senior sex crimes prosecutor to the case
but when we reached out for official
comment the District Attorney's Office
told us as this remains very much an
active investigation we will decline to
comment now paz de la Huerta is lawyer
responded to the news reporting telling
CBS News the DA's office will has
copious amounts of evidence and no
reason to delay indictment they urged
the district attorney to convene a grand
jury by the end of next week or expect
the protests to begin Harvey Weinstein
has vehemently denied any allegations of
non-consensual sex but it does seem to
be a big change with no explanation it
does and you know I actually just
interviewed the district attorney on
Wednesday we were talking about an
unrelated story but he said that this
was an active investigation so to hear
that they may not be going forward with
this now is definitely new and you're
just hearing from her attorneys right
now acts absolutely we just got a
statement this morning all right Trika
thank you very much